hello milkshakers it's me one of your
hosts rain wilson welcome to the show
yes welcome to the show i am the other
of your hosts reza aslan rayne you look
a little down but uh you doing all right
i'm fine um
i'm fine i just uh one of our guinea
pigs passed away and
yeah stripey
and um
yeah he he would boy he took a licking
and kept on ticking he was like an
eight-year-old
guinea pig defied like every every
guinea pig
life expectancy so we're we're grateful
for stripey but um
yeah it's a little sad a little sad let
me ask you this do you um
do you still sense stripey in the house
like do you do you feel like his spirit
is like hanging out in the comments now
stripey
um
yeah
sure sure i do what about you what about
you reza
do i believe in in stripey uh
yeah i mean why not
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
no but i'll tell you uh i don't
necessarily believe in in stripey
visiting me razzabot
i do think
there's more to death
than
just lights out at the end of the life
of our body and people know that who've
been listening to the show um
but i have a crazy story for you
so
about that so um
my uh friend that i went to college with
he used to love uh motorcycles and he
was a motorcycle delivery guy in l.a for
a long time his wife got cancer was
about 20 years ago
and she
uh was passing away
and he's just a die-hard atheist and uh
english guy
named ron and and ron said to uh his
wife
who was passing like listen
um
if if you're there if you're on the
other side you've got to send me a sign
send me a sign
that only i would know um and he had
spent months taking care of her and and
whatnot as she was as she was passing
and she was like okay i'm going to send
you a sign
show me that there's proof on the other
side so she passes away
they have a ceremony a funeral it's all
very sad blah blah and then he's
grieving it's just awful etc and then
finally he's gonna go
uh ride his motorcycle he has several
motorcycles he takes out his his
favorite
italian racing bike oh by the way she
died at like
3 16 in the morning or something like
that and they he had to like sign the
death certificate and had the time of
death on the death certificate he
finally was like i'm gonna ride my
italian racing bike and he took the
cover off of it and it didn't start and
he had to like charge it and stuff like
that and
just started it and it has a it had a
little clock on it and the clock was at
3 16. and he saw that
and he was like oh my god that's the
sign that's that's the only thing that
she could have sent just directly
to me the time of death the clock had
had stopped what do you think wow so
it's like uh it's like death
communication that i mean look this we
we hear stuff like this all the time
sure no
near-death experiences i had a
kind of a near-death
experience it was i wish i followed
through
thanks
thanks i appreciate that
uh
you know it wasn't like look it wasn't
the kind of uh near-death experience
that you hear a lot you know with like
tunnels and lights and like you know
people on the other side in the warm
glowy feeling although actually it did
have it did involve a warm glowy feeling
i was i was a river hiking with some
friends but like we separated and for
some stupid reason i kept going
and got caught a little bit of a of a
current
and went under went under and and my
foot was stuck uh on a rock and
i remember very clearly like
the the water was only maybe a few
inches above my face but i couldn't get
to it you know like i could see the
water you couldn't you were stuck under
the water you couldn't get your head up
to take a breath i couldn't yeah exactly
i couldn't get my head up above the
surface which was only maybe six inches
above me but as far as i could go i was
still about six inches away because my
foot was stuck
uh in this and this rock at the bottom
of the
the river and uh and i remember i like i
panicked i was panicking you know like
oh [ __ ] like this is it yeah sure oh god
at first it's kind of like inconvenient
and it's sort of funny and wow i can't
wait to tell this story to my friends
and then it's not funny anymore and then
it's panic and i remember
i still remember this was again i was in
high school so this was a long time ago
like maybe four or five years ago
um and uh
i remember as clear as day the moment in
which i realized well
i guess that's that
and
just
kinda
let it go like i this is how i re this
is how i remember it i just
kinda
gave in
and relaxed
and it was calm
and it was quiet it was beautiful
and i remember like the sun was shining
you know through the surface of the
water and i could see all the colors
and it was just this like
you know people talk about like
that overwhelming sense of peace
you know that's that's what it was
that's what it was it was no there was
no light at the end of the tunnel no you
know other people or beings or whatever
but just this
overwhelming sense of just peace
and satisfaction
and then of course
the irony is i think what happened is
because i finally relaxed
my leg came loose
and oh i like popped up i popped up out
of the surface
and
what i remember about that
is that i caught up with my friends
and i was like you guys you guys
oh my god like i almost died and they
were like whoa that's crazy no no no no
no look i
like i basically
died they're like yeah that's nuts man
crazy and i was like you know what
no matter what i say like no one no one
gets it like there's no way anyone could
understand what i'm saying because it's
just about my own personal experience
like there's no point
in trying to like prove what just
happened or or to kind of force other
people to understand it the way that i
intuitively understood it's like your
friend like you know we could say oh
it's just a coincidence or whatever but
he
knew that something different was
happening because he was the one
experiencing it
that's amazing wow that i had no idea it
was that serious razza you were almost
to the point where your life was
flashing before your eyes
almost if i had been there
i would have been like are you ready
are you ready to pass on i would have
shouted
down and if you would have nodded like i
would have held you down you know i
would have let you i would have said
peace go in peace you know
you're in pain right now
let it let it go
how weird would it have been if like my
high school self
in that moment of near death
suddenly saw rayne wilson
like well that's weird that's a face i'm
never gonna forget
look we joke we joke but
people like this is a serious thing
people have had near-death experiences
throughout history
there's a universality to them yep and
you know it's hard not to just kind of
[ __ ] on it like ah [ __ ] you know or
whatever which is why we invited
leslie kane on the podcast today leslie
kane is an investigative journalist and
author notable for books about ufos and
the afterlife
she um went to bard college she's a
journalist investigative journalist
a serious person very serious person has
published works-related ufos since the
year 2000 she's been on coast-to-coast
am one of my favorite shows
thank you very much
um and her book surviving death was the
basis for a six-part documentary series
on netflix of the same name which
launched last year 2021 she was a
consulting producer and she says the
first episode is magnificent if you're
gonna check it out to really really
check out and underline that first that
very first episode of surviving death
and this book is pretty remarkable folks
um
it uh is surviving death a journalist
investigates evidence for an afterlife
and there's so many different facets of
death she investigates mediums
and seances and past lives and
near-death experiences which we are
going to investigate and um
super incredible bone chilling stories
throughout as kind of as well documented
as any work
about this topic could be
evidence just like the subtitle says
leslie kane thank you for joining us on
the metaphysical milkshake pod it's such
a delight to have you here
i am so thrilled to be with you guys
i've really been looking forward to this
and it's an honor to be with such
brilliant people as you so well thank
you very much wow and rain is awesome
i've been called brilliant
yeah i think you are
thank you well you are shiny rain you
are so that's kind of what brilliant
sort of means you
you you definitely glow i need powder
mostly it makes people laugh
that's important
the book as we were talking about is
called surviving death
a journalist investigates evidence for
an afterlife and what we loved about
this book is like look
there are a lot of books about like
death and the afterlife and what happens
on the other side and stuff but this one
was great because it's actually like
scientifically grounded like there's
actual survey and data and evidence
which ray and i get very nerdy about uh
whenever that stuff starts to come up
and store it and let's not forget
chock-a-block with like stories stories
that are some of which i've read before
they're jaw-dropping and they're
they're verified i mean you can't
scientifically prove a story but they're
very
they're real yeah yeah a lot of
goosebumps a lot of goosebumps uh in
this book
on that note on the note of you know the
storytelling and the and the and the you
know
the data and the and the research that
goes into this thing you say basically
you've said this in a previous interview
while exploring the evidence for an
afterlife i witnessed some unbelievable
things that are not supposed to be
possible in our material world yep they
were unavoidably and undeniably real
despite my initial doubt i came to
realize that there are still aspects of
nature which are neither understood or
accepted even though the reality has
profound implications for understanding
the true breadth of the human psyche and
its possible continuity after death so
like
what what what what was it that you
actually witnessed
but yeah i mean that's a huge question
because there was a lot um but i think
what i was probably thinking of most
when i wrote that line
which it
goes to the most weird stuff which we
probably don't want to get on fir get to
first but that since you asked me you
know
you know material materializations that
occur in physical seances um that's
absolutely verifiable and i've witnessed
it myself okay tell us
give us a let's just go right into it
because we have a lot of skeptics
listening to this podcast yeah this is a
hard one to get by the skeptic so i tend
to save it for the last that's why i
saved it for the very end of the book
because i i built up gradually to this
you know i talked about some of the
historical data on it and and led people
into it kind of uh so i don't know
we like to dive into the deep end here
let's do it we're gonna do it backwards
leslie go ahead all right we'll do it
backwards so
um
i don't know how many people even know
what physical mediumship is i think most
people think it's all [ __ ] it's
fraud it's it's you know ridiculous it's
people sitting in the dark and fooling
other people and playing tricks and all
that
and um i understand that people think
that because they haven't studied the
literature on it there's a lot of
literature on it showing that some
mediums had these incredible abilities
back in the heyday of mediumship which
was the 1920s around that time
when
some of our best scientists actually
studied them under controlled conditions
so they were able to eliminate any
possibility of fraud and i could spend a
whole hour just talking about that but
i'm not going to do it because there's a
wealth of literature for people if they
want to find out what that is it's there
sure yeah um and you just have to take
my word for it i'm not going to be
fooled you know that these scientists
wrote these tomes
laying out everything they did and it's
without question
uh objective and and validates what they
what they saw and they went in expecting
to be able to prove fraud and they
couldn't
so with that as a background um just the
fact that this stuff actually has
happened historically is amazing enough
in itself and i do i do give cases of
that in my book um and but but in terms
of my own personal experience i was able
to find a contemporary medium
who is doing this now and it's pretty
rare now uh there aren't many mediums
physical mediums out there that
you know are untainted by any
accusations of fraud who aren't making a
lot of money and traveling around the
world and doing all the stuff that makes
you raise questions
um and so you can you can ask me
whatever you want i don't know if people
even know what physical mediumship is
maybe you want me to explain that yeah
well you kind of said it sort of like
you know when you think of when you
think of a seance or something right
yeah i mean it's basically an individual
who has the ability to go into a deep
trance state so
in the case of the medium i know his
name is stuart and we'll just use
stewart alexander we'll use him as an
example stuart will go into a very deep
trance state he's completely unconscious
throughout the whole meeting or seance
it's called a seance
he doesn't even know what's happened
until he comes back at the end and what
happens is the spirit and i'm just going
to tell you how it is as they tell us
it's happening
i mean people can have all kinds of
other ways of explaining it but what it
was what is happening is that they're
spirit
people spirit entities that speak
through that medium in that seance
there's a small group of sitters
and those entities will use the vocal
cords of the medium and make all these
things happen in the room that are
physically impossible but they they make
them happen
such as levitations of objects that fly
all around the room um
uh voices that speak out of thin air
they're not only speaking through vocal
cords of the medium there's a
there are things that materialize in the
room and dematerialize
uh matter can be taken through matter so
there's one thing where they pull a
strap through the arm of the medium
so anyway all these these really amazing
things happen plus there's
communications that come through from
deceased people so the sitters in the
room can hear messages from their loved
ones
and it's um it is i mean it's it's
unbelievably hard for anyone to accept
it i completely get that uh it's like
going into another world it's sort of
like you're joining the physical world
with
this other world and you're meeting
somewhere in the middle
um because it is like you go into this
space and it's like entering another
reality and i've done it for since since
about 2015 i've done this many many many
times i've completely checked out
this medium to make sure there was
nothing happening in his room that that
was at all
fraudulent he's been practicing for 50
years and it's never been found of
committed fraud he's practiced all over
the place been studied by various people
he's restrained there's all kinds of
controls on it so you know these things
are actually happening and
it's pretty life-changing when you
experience something that is completely
unexplainable by the physics and the
sciences we understand it
and and there's nobody seems to be
interested that that's that's the thing
too no none of the scientists seem to be
we're interested
well unemployed actors are very
interested
good
[Music]
folks before you book any brunch you
pour over lists and lists of reviews
that's what i do
so why not do the same when you're
booking a doctor's appointment with
zocdoc you can see real verified patient
reviews to help find the right doctor in
your network and in your neighborhood
after all finding the right doctor is
just as if not more important than
finding the right plate of eggs benedict
zocdoc
is a free app
and it shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed that take your insurance and
are available when you need them on
zocdoc you can find every specialist
under the sun whether you're trying to
straighten those teeth fix an inky back
get that mold checked out or anything
else zocdoc has you covered zocdoc's
mobile app is as easy as ordering a ride
to a restaurant or getting delivery to
your house
search find and book doctors with a few
taps find and review local doctors read
verified patient reviews from real
people who made real appointments and
now when you walk into that doctor's
office you're all set to see someone in
your network who gets you go to
zocdoc.com find the doctor that is right
for you and book an appointment in
person or remotely that works for your
schedule every month millions of people
use zocdoc and you know what i'm one of
them
it's my go-to whenever i need to find
and book a quality doctor go to
zocdoc.com
milkshake and download the zocdoc app
for free then start your search for a
top rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's z o c
d o c
dot com slash milkshake zocdoc dot com
slash milkshake
in the back of your book here you have
some diagrams of what you personally
experienced now i'm i'm
i couldn't be more skeptical about this
now i'm very open-minded about ghosts
and certainly about near-death
experiences i've talked to people that
have had them and i really want to dive
into that specific
facet of your studies but here in the
end of your book you're talking about
stuart channeling someone named walter
and for those watching on youtube
there's
as an you had an experience with an
ectoplasm
what happened
well i mean i had multiple experiences
and as have others for decades i just
want you to know i'm not the only one
um no of course what happens is so
there's this substance this energy
substance that gets exuded from the
medium's body and this has been
documented again in all these historical
studies done by scientists back in you
know years ago
um i mean i know it's really hard to
believe but it's
rectoplasm exists it's some kind of
energy substance that comes out of the
medium
and whatever these energies are in the
room that are making all these things
happen can manipulate this ectoplasm and
do various things with it that's how
they do all these things in the room so
the experiment what they call an
experiment that you're talking about is
uh there's a table in front of the
medium his arms are strapped i mean this
is not his hand and i can give you a
zillion reasons why i know that it's not
his hand but you see this cloud of
ectoplasm
come over a table that's lit underneath
so that it's sort of silhouetted against
the lit table
and it's like it looks sort of like
water it's this very kind of fluid
moving uh substance
that that comes closer and closer to the
person sitting on the other side of the
table which is me or some anyone else
and you you you'll see that a a hand
start to form in this moving stuff you
sort of see these digits appear and then
it becomes three-dimensional in a moment
you see this thing lift up off the table
and bang on the table making a sound
so it's physical and then
at the hand with just when i experienced
it the hand came back a second time and
i was able to hold it and touch it and
feel it
until it withdrew again and it was
basically uh felt like a normal i mean
there are some things about it that were
a little strange but it was basically a
living human hand
that was materialized out of nothing out
of this thing called ectoplasm it didn't
exist and you you saw that and you've
seen this several times multiple times
multiple times ghostbusters type hands
on the table yes
it kind of is i guess if you want to
look at it that way
no i mean ghostbusters unfortunately
made a joke out of the word ectoplasm
but it is it's a it's a very
well-documented documented phenomenon
there are pictures of it and there's all
you know scientists as i've said over
and over again
nobel prize winning scientist sir
william crooks who is one of the leading
scientists of the 19th century they've
all studied this and documented it so
for anybody who knows the literature
it's not that weird a thing to think
about but for somebody who's only
watched ghostbusters yeah it's going to
make you laugh you know
it's just there's there's a hidden world
here there's a hidden world that nobody
really knows about
well it's you know it's just it's lovely
to hear you talk about this because
you know
you went into this uh as a rational
investigative reporter like you were
there to do the kind of investigative
work that you've done for your entire
career it's just you're investigating in
this particular case something that is
you know
uh metaphysical uh perhaps spiritual you
know something that is very difficult to
explain using just you know the
the natural laws of physics that that
we're all uh accustomed to
um but one of the things that i love in
listening to you talk about this strange
experience is that it reminds me a lot
of like the way that reign and i often
talk about faith right that faith is an
experience like why do you believe in
god because you had certain experiences
that made you believe you know in this
kind of immaterial realm which makes it
ridiculous you can't like have an uh an
argument with someone who doesn't
believe in god you know based on well i
had this particular experience and i
find that same thing kind of happening
in this conversation where it's like
look i could talk about this all day if
you want me to but the only thing that i
can tell you is that i experienced it i
felt it i know it's real
and i can tell you about it but unless
you yourself experience it you know you
can kind of take it or leave it
yeah i mean that's so true and i think i
in the book throughout there's there's
certain evidence that i think is more
objective right that people might be
able to accept without experiencing it
and then there's other evidence that
that is as you say it comes from your
own experience and the ultimately it's
the personal experience that's going to
be more
impactful on anyone including a
journalist leslie the reason
that we most wanted to speak to you was
a topic that reza and i are obsessed
with and that is near-death experiences
i really urge
the listeners the viewers
to
go down
on a very particular rabbit hole which
is just start watching youtube videos
about near-death experiences a lot of
them are very cheesy i get it i know
they've got cheesy music and little
pictures of angels and stuff like that
but if you listen to the actual stories
themselves
it is
um it's astonishing and
what's astonishing are these common
traits that you write about and have
been written about before
there's um uh they're very well
documented um a sense an awareness of
being dead a sense of peace an out of
body experience often looking down on
the body there's kind of experience with
light with love going down a tunnel
encountering beings of light having
reliving it euphoric and you know uh
environments having your life flashed
through your eyes etc
it goes on and on now some people only
experience the first two or three and
some go farther and farther in those
experiences to me it's uh it's
fascinating and
there have been incredible
documentations of of ones from previous
centuries
and it's always these key foundational
aspects of the experience but
in in your in your research in your
writing in the interviews that you did
um
again if how can we approach this
scientifically if not scientifically
then at least journalistically
what is undeniable about ndes
and then ultimately how does this
reframe death itself yeah i mean that's
a huge question and i agree with you
they're absolutely fascinating and the
fact that they occur all over the world
as you said you know there's there's
thousands of these events and and is
that true because are do they happen in
papua new guinea and in mongolia and
well um i mean i can't say that i know
but let's just say the countries that
have been you know that where people
have that have been studied i mean there
are a lot of countries that have been
studied and i'm not the one doing that
so i can't say for sure but there are
certain people that like for instance
jeffrey long whose work you probably are
aware of
um
you know i think in terms of the
scientific element of it i think one of
the things that there are medical
doctors in particular that have taken
this on and studied it scientifically
they do a lot of um surveys so they do a
lot of work with numbers and and kind of
sorting out like how often does this
certain to certain elements of it show
up
uh what are the percentages of different
things that happen what are the
commonalities of it you know are there
do the religious figures depend on the
religion that you have that you might
encounter i mean they've done all this
sort of statistical analysis on it
um the only other thing they can do
scientifically is address the skeptical
arguments and show that they are not
valid through various scientific
knowledge that they have and they have
an ability to do that
but i think beyond that
there's not a whole lot they can do
because it's unexplainable by science
and you have to you have to have the
foundation
that consciousness operates
independently of the brain in order to
accept this reality of ndes and i think
the scientific materialist world is not
does not believe that
you can't accept it
and so
you know you have to that's the
foundation that you have to shift over
to
and that's hard to prove i mean there
are plenty of good arguments for it and
i believe that it's the case and i'm
sure you guys have read pim von lummel's
work for instance if you're into into
this
you know who who he's just fantastic at
explaining like why he believes that the
consciousness functions independently of
the brain i mean he's seen it you see it
with this with these ndes because
while they happen
the person has no brain function if you
want to look at the most hardcore really
evidential nb ndes
the person has no brain function zero
which means they can't think they have
no ability to be active or have thoughts
or remember anything or to hallucinate
or all the things that
you know to travel off and come back or
to even be in the room and report back
actual factual things that that can be
verified afterwards people that go out
during surgery say
when they're completely without brain
activity they're they've no heartbeat
they're being resuscitated you know all
the situations they're they're doing all
this without a brain
so when they're when they're what they
report back can be verified
how can you explain that other than to
accept that they were abs they were able
to be conscious without their brain
yeah this idea that consciousness is not
locked in the brain that it
actually is
um
a product of multiple
functions of the body and
that you know i think some of the really
interesting cognitive research that's
being done here we had this whole
conversation with andy murphy paul about
this
this idea um
is that
you know consciousness can be affected
by external
uh stimuli external forces etc etc so
it is becoming i think a little bit more
accepted this idea of
consciousness existing outside of the
brain in scientific circles but
i'm curious in in the the experiential
stuff that you did here you know not so
much the scientific research um what
what kind of conclusions did you come to
when it comes to consciousness like is
is consciousness in your view sort of
who we are is it basically another word
for soul
it's such a good question i mean i
certainly came away from this work
feeling that it's
it's something independent of the brain
that the brain is more like a receiver
um
for consciousness that it you know and
that perhaps consciousness is what's
fundamental
to our existence as opposed to matter i
mean there that's more of a
philosophical question but
there are many many powerful thinkers
who believe that's the case you know
that
first there's consciousness then there's
matter
and i don't have the answers um
but
i've had enough experiences to believe
that
consciousness is what ivan lomo calls it
non-local it's not generated by the
brain it's not local to the brain
it's something way bigger than that it's
so well documented that there's
something else going on here but how to
characterize that i don't really know
well i don't really know what it means
our fearless researcher
um
safa came up with
old uh historical um
ndes the one that really caught my eye
was british admiral sir francis bufort
he almost drowned in 1791
and he wrote in his journals a calm
feeling of the most perfect tranquility
succeeded
the most tumultuous sensation nor was i
in any bodily pain on the contrary my
sensations were now of a rather
pleasurable cast
though the senses were thus deadened not
so the mind its activity seemed to be
invigorated in a ratio which defies all
description
for thought rose after thought with a
rapidity of succession that is not only
indescribable but probably inconceivable
by anyone who has been himself in a
similar situation
the course of these thoughts i can even
now in a great measure retrace every
incident of my past life seemed to me to
glance across my recollection in
retrograde procession the whole period
of my existence seemed to be placed
before me in a kind of panoramic view
he writes about that so well and this
was so long ago the 18th century
and wow um
the
the chapter that you wrote and i had
actually heard this story before about
maria
and the shoe so
incredible story of a woman having a
near-death experience she's like you've
said leslie or she was brain dead
and came back and described
how she floated above her body and she's
pointed at the corner i was floating
right up there and then i went up above
the hospital and she described what she
saw kind of seeing her body in the room
still but also seeing the hospital below
her and she talked about a shoe
seeing this shoe and so this nurse went
on this detective hunt for this shoe and
looked around looked through every
window in the hospital couldn't find any
shoe finally like went outside the
hospital through one panorama and could
see that there was a shoe that had been
described by maria perfectly that she
could never could have seen
you would have had to have been in a
helicopter over the hospital in order to
have seen this shoe and
it was really chilling are there those
are a couple of stories are there are
there other specific stories that you
heard or people you spoke to or uh
something that you
experienced that really just sealed the
deal for you
goosebumps stories
yeah so i mean the other case that's
really compelling is the case of pam
reynolds which you guys are probably
familiar with it's one of the most
famous
near-death experience cases
and i actually in my book i have her
telling it in her own words she's no
longer she died but she did a a long
interview with some colleagues of mine
and it's all transcribed in my book but
are you mean you want me to talk about
that case yeah please um yeah because um
tell the story
yeah i mean what was amazing about her
case was she she was a young woman who
had this aneurysm underneath her skull
in the you know buried in her brain that
was really life-threatening
and she did this a very extreme uh
procedure which was the only only chance
she had of surviving
uh which was that they
they actually drained all the blood out
of her body
and and took her body temperature down
to something like 68 degrees as cold as
they could get it
without you know with her being alive
put her on all these machines drained
all the body all the blood out of her
body she was brain dead as brain dead as
you could possibly be i mean the doctor
has testified to that no activity at all
for probably 40 minutes or something
she had loud clicking sounds in her ears
because of machinery that was being used
for the for the surgery she you know the
whole sk her whole skull was removed it
was just horrifying
this clicking noise in her ears and and
something over her eyes so she couldn't
see her hear anything so she describes
going out of her body and the first
thing she did was she saw all the stuff
in the room
which
she described you know she was able to
see what the tools was that they were
using which she thought were weird
because they weren't what she expected
she heard what they said she saw who was
in the room none of which she had seen
before she was anesthetized
and then she went off and had the
near-death experience of seeing a light
and and following the light and talking
to some dead relatives and then
not wanting to come back
but to describes how one of them just
kind of forced her to jump back into her
body it was just you know i mean
the near-death experience part the part
where she goes off in the light and
talks to her relatives there's no
verification that you can ever do for
that but she witnessed so much in that
room from the perspective of being in
the ceiling
right down to the the the tone that the
uh
one of the tools made she said it looked
like an electric toothbrush it was some
kind of a specialized saw that they were
using but she said it looked like an
electric toothbrush and it made she was
a musician so she recognized it as a the
note d
and um
that kind of detail she saw the case
where other parts were kept she saw
there was a woman who made a comment all
of this she told the doctor when she
woke up and he was completely you know
didn't know how to explain she because
she had no brain activity how could she
possibly
have
experienced all of this and even the
skeptics who want to say that she some
skeptics will say well she had you can
wake up when you're under anesthesia
but that's where the importance of these
noise machines and and covers over her
eyes come in there's you know there's no
way she could have received any of this
so it's just it's a really really
evidential case because there were so
many accurate things she reported and
because we have this
very well-known
highly trained surgeon who was
world renowned for doing this kind of
you know the
surgery that he did who was able to
verify
that everything that she said was
actually what happened in that room and
he had absolutely no way of explaining
it
so
let's get to the the heart of the matter
shall we
drink and cry
i mean knowing what you know now and the
research that you've done and the
experiences that you've had and the
stories that you've heard and written
about
i guess the question is what do you
think death actually is what is death
well it's certainly the end of the
physical body
we all agree on that um
but then the question is does any part
of our consciousness survive that is
there anything else that happens you
know do we survive that
and that's the question i pose in the
book i don't feel like i know 100
i think there's very
highly suggestive evidence of the fact
that that could that could be the case
i don't know for sure you know and i i
just sort of dwell in the mystery of it
i mean
i read a lot learn a lot and there's
never a concrete answer
uh but you just have to i think for each
person it depends on what
is evidential for you as a person what
experience you've had yourself that
might convince you of something like
this
so i don't know it's hard to give like a
blanket answer but um i certainly
find it hard i i mean i i think it's
very likely that something survives
and the other thing to remember too like
about near-death experiences and a lot
of these other experiences is that
people describe them as more real
than than the world we live in here in
the physical world
right that's incredible more clear more
real that's always striking vivid
isn't that striking
and i think that's true that really says
something about the possibility of there
being some other reality you know and
it's and it i don't think it's just ndes
there are other experiences where those
same kinds of descriptions are given
so um
i think even with some ufo experiences
people have that kind of perception so
i don't know i've had i just i'm really
i pretty much believe that something
something's going on it's not just
fantasy that humans are creating and to
make all these miraculous things happen
i wish i could give you more wisdom here
but
i think what someone needs to have an
nde
while being abducted by an aliens
anyway well some people feel like
they're there there's a lot of
similarities between the two realities
and maybe they're almost the same thing
would it be fair to say that however
else you want to define death
that fundamentally
it seems like it's not the end i i think
so
and i think you're a scholar of
religions all the religions say that
right right
every single one of them is based on
that premise so
i was curious how you perceive all of
this from that perspective
i mean it's as you say it's universal
it's just different
ways of describing
what we now refer to as you know ndes uh
or or
you know
the the the all the scientific rigor and
the work that you've done and and the
research it's just a kind of
mythologizing
of of all of that so you know to reigns
point
we have
personal anecdotal evidence of
near-death experiences that go back to
you know british admirals 200
uh and plus 300 years ago
well we have similar things
going back to what we would now refer to
as shaman or
prophets that go back
10 000 years ago you know so
um
yeah this is this seems to be a
fundamental
part of the human experience which is
that whatever is happening in this
material realm
this is not the end that whatever we are
fundamentally
consciousness soul however you want to
whatever word you want to use chi
uh
you know brahma uh however you want to
define it
it continues
it goes on
and i guess you know if you want to wax
even further metaphysically
you would say
you know if you're a materialist and you
believe that uh life is done when the
body is done um
and when the you know the heartbeat
stops that's that's one way to live your
life and there's nothing wrong with that
and one can certainly say and many kind
of materialist atheists do say that
they find that very inspiring because
it's like live every day like it's your
last and make the most of it and don't
be living for some mythological next
world or what have you but if you
believe that death is not the end if you
don't believe that lights out death if
there is something more like what does
that mean then what does that mean
to our life what does that mean to the
choices that we make what kind of
reverberations does that have
what is that speak of
something beyond something transcendent
leslie any thoughts on that yeah i mean
that's really an important element of it
because i i kept wanting to say it's not
just about
when we die it's about
in this reality now that there is much
more to reality
than just the physical the world and the
what can be perceived by the five senses
the material is paradigm that's not
reality
and so it's not just about what happens
when you die it's like what's happening
now what is reality
what role does consciousness play
in um all of it and what does it mean i
mean i think those are the those are
those are the questions that interest me
even more really
than
what happens when you die and of course
they're really connected
but um i think you know it i mean one of
the things that's happened to me is this
much bigger sense of connectedness
to
other people to
uh
some kind of core reality that we all
share i don't know i
i feel a sense of expanded consciousness
also from having had all these
experiences um i feel you know
open and eager for
more
kind of transcendent experiences for
anything that shows me again
that the physical world is not
all there is i love nothing more than to
be shown that
and um
[Music]
it's just life-changing it just it i
don't know it's very hard to put into
words i i'm sure you guys have had
similar experiences where you just feel
like you you understand the world in a
different way
right it's not about
what your senses perceive it's about
trying to get beyond that and trying to
understand something deeper
and um
yeah i feel like i've had a lot of
experiences that have touched i where
i've been able to touch that other
reality and that's what means more to me
than anything else so
i'm more concerned about right now than
what happens when i die but of course
they're connected so
the book is called surviving death a
journalist investigates evidence for an
afterlife leslie kane thank you so much
this was so much for us to think about
we really appreciate you coming on the
podcast
thank you for having me i feel like we
just got started because there was a lot
to think about so it's great to talk to
both of you think about it there's a lot
more to dive into sorry we don't
do it but really fun book
i'd be happy to talk to you guys again
yeah
yes
well that was fun
that was fun but reza i gotta say that i
think our metaphysical podcast card is
is gonna get pulled i think i am
imagining about two-thirds of our
audience right now going like what the
[ __ ] you guys
this is not i get to coast a.m
i get it i get it you know and
you know i don't i honestly don't know
what to say to that audience and i like
i like that leslie was like look i'm not
gonna try to prove any of this to you
okay i mean if you wanna if you want
proof go out there and uh and find it
and i kind of feel the the same way
which is that do i what do i believe
about this am i you know how do i feel
about
near-death experiences and and about you
know ectoplasm ectoplasmic hands
grabbing you yeah
ectoplasmic hand jobs and and all of
that which i'm open to
that's interesting i'm very open to that
all of which is to say
i like where she ended it
you know we asked her
what is death and she was like well i
don't know
but
um
this study of death and these near-death
experiences and these issues of past
lives and possible reincarnation and
like you know seances and ectoplasmic
hand jobs and all of that
makes me think that maybe we should
rethink not what we think about death
but what we think about life
like maybe
reality
isn't necessarily what you think it is
maybe there is more
maybe there is a
another way of thinking about reality
maybe maybe what we think of reality is
just this kind of
veil that is right in front of our face
it kind of blinders that only allows us
to see you know a few feet in front of
us
and we think that's real we think that's
reality because you know we've never
really taken the blinders off and maybe
looking at death allows us to take the
blinders off a little bit and be like i
don't know maybe reality isn't what you
think it is yeah and i think that that
would need to incorporate science
so for sure what does that look like i
mean it looks like the fact that they
discovered that oh hello dark energy and
dark matter is actually uh 95 of them of
the universe we were wrong about it all
being just matter
in atoms and molecules it's it's it's
far more complicated so you know and if
you expand that view then
i like your line of thought where the
material universe
is real it is reality and it's filled
with scientific
laws that govern how it works that we
continue to learn and expand upon over
time
but it's not all of reality that there
are
resonances of other
realities uh
you know expanding ever outwards from
our
quote unquote like you said what's right
in front of our face
and you know what bothers me sometimes
and we've we've talked a lot about
science what science is what science
does how to understand what science is
the the
intersection of science and religion and
all those things we've had a lot of
conversations about that over the the
many many episodes of this this podcast
but it always cracks me up that
you know there's a there's this
criticism uh towards certain people of
faith right which is all about
um
you know
the the definition of supernatural and
scientists will often say like well what
you think is a supernatural experience
is just that science hasn't caught up to
it yet you know that science will
redefine what is natural with each new
um investigation with each new discovery
and
uh you know it's the god in the voids
argument right that there's something i
can't explain and so therefore i call it
god and science says yeah but just give
us some time and we'll explain it and so
therefore you don't need god which is a
fine argument i don't have a problem
with that i'm not i'm not a god in the
void kind of person
but the flip side of that
which always drives me crazy is that
when science looks at
near-death experience or telekinesis
they say well that's ridiculous that's
not science and it's like well not yet
all right you know let me give us like
not give us time and give us time and
make it
science there may very well be within
the next 50 years
experiments scientific experiments with
hard data that prove near-death
experiences
to
you know the in in a way that it is
just like the unidentified aerial
phenomenon we're finding these days in a
way that's it's it's it's
unarguable um we don't have that yet but
hopefully some money will be spent maybe
we i don't even know what that would
look like but um
that would be
that would change
the world
yeah and by the way
what scientists worth their salt
would disagree with that statement
yeah right what scientists with their
salt would say no no there's something
that science can't answer
you know
that's not how it works like you know
let's let's see let's see we barely know
how the brain works for pete's sake you
know who knows
what do you guys think uh milkshakers uh
do you believe in life after death have
you had a near-death experience that
would be cool we'd love to hear from you
uh any any kind of you know uh
experience with uh mediums or or
have you communicated
with the afterlife you know all that
stuff you know how rain and i get
absolutely nuts about that if you've got
something let us know you can find us on
social media at reza aslan rayne wilson
we're on also on twitter at
metamilkpodcast
on instagram
metaphysicalmilkshake let us know have
you ever died and we will be giving away
two copies
of
surviving death what you need to do is
leave us a good review on apple podcasts
take a screenshot send it in to
metaphysical
cast with the k
and
you'll get a nice free book two of you
two lucky listeners
thank you so much for tuning in uh make
sure to subscribe to our metaphysical
milkshake youtube channel and you can
watch us having these scintillating
conversations
see you next week
see you next week assuming we're both
alive still
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick demaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner in original music
by jeff tan
[Music]
or
you know communication with the world or
ectoplasmic hand jobs and yeah i've said
that phrase four times um
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you